What I've shown you in the beginning of class have from a coin flip to a binomial distribution
all the way to a normal distribution, and you might think that this was challenging and indeed it was.
As it turns out, you can treat all this things about the same.
In fact, if you're a medical doctor and you have one patient, you might think of it as a coin flip.
If you have 10 patients, you might think of it as binomial distribution.
If you do what's normally done, when your test say a new drug and you have, say 10,000 patients
then this thing over here is a beautiful and very compact representation of it.
Otherwise, it would be almost impossible to compute.
That's the purpose of normal distribution for the sake of this class.
As you go forward and look into hypotheses testing and confidence then develops.
You don't do this for this relatively complicated expressions over here.
We just do it for the normal distribution that I think relatively easy to compute.
Welcome to the world of normal distributions.